Okay--onto a new concept: this is the concept of Validation.
Validation basically means
verifying, on the Server side, that what we received
is what we expected to receive.
So we have you, and we have our Servers--
and you're submitting to our form certain values.
Let's say you're sending the "q" parameter.
It's a checkbox that we've put on our form
and its value equals "on".
And the Server receives that and knows what to do if "q" equals "on",
and it knows what to do if "q" is not present--
you know--that means the checkbox wasn't checked.
But what if there's a bad guy
and he's wearing a hat, and he submits to our Server
the "q" parameter--but instead of equaling "on" or not being present,
he submits the word, "broken"?
Now, depending on how our Server is programmed--
you know--it can just say
oh, well I don't know what "broken" means
so I'm just going to assume it's unchecked,
which is probably the smart thing to do.
And that's great.
The point I'm trying to make, however,
is that just because we have a form with a checkbox on it
that limits what a user can send us--through the form--
it doesn't mean that somebody can't send, directly to our Server,
parameters with arbitrary junk in them.
And it's up to our Server to make sure that we handle it safely.
Always remember that your Server can receive junk
and it needs to be smart enough
to deal with somebody sending completely broken data.
And it doesn't necessarily have to be the string, "broken", right?
This could be a megabyte of trash,
and you don't want to just blindly do something with it.
So make sure you're always validating your parameters,
and that's what we're going to talk about now.